new in theaters this weekend the ugly
dolls long shot and the intruder what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
welcome to ugly veil friend ugly dolls
comes out this weekend this
computer-animated feel good family film
follows the story of rejected defective
plush dolls as they travel to the town
of perfection where they learn that they
are considered not necessarily perfect
you're an engineer slash model my
accessories will make me different or a
lawyer
slash model I'm an individual exactly
like the rest of you the perfect dolls
get to be loved by real human children
and the ugly dolls get shut out of a
tube into their town of ugly Vil
ultimately they learn that the perfect
dolls have problems too and being true
to yourself is better than being perfect
are we really not good enough for the
big world no our flaws make us unique
those are all worth fighting for
oh and it's a musical look oh and it's a
musical with Kelly Clarkson Nick Jonas
Janelle Monae black shell black Shelton
it does still sound like a cowboy though
a black Shelton you ain't going nowhere
Blake Shelton and pitbull I love pitbull
crazy
this look is for you if you like
musicals with a strong positive message
you're looking for a family flick this
weekend or dolls man so much fun right
in the button
I would like to endorse you to be the
next president of the United States oh
my god you've been a great Secretary of
State which state again all of them will
I not see a movie this weekend not by a
longshot
what movie will I see longshot new in
theaters this week this Seth Rogen and
Charlize Theron romantic comedy will
make you laugh and feel the warm and
fuzzies I look forward to working with
you she touched my heart I'm someone
people go through like great lengths not
to touch the gay dude down and out
journalist Fred flower speed is tasked
with following around and reporting on
Secretary of State Charlotte field turns
out she used to babysit him when they
were kids and now the heat is on do they
fall in love it's a long shot but
probably we actually
we need to move you Thank You agent M
this movie is for you if you like goofy
Seth Rogen put in an awkward situation
movies rom-coms are your thing or
secretaries of state man so much fun my
great-great-grandfather built this
hospital foxglove is your stuff what's
it good camera so fast and finally out
this weekend of the intruder have you
ever liked me had dreams of Dennis Quaid
mowing your lawn well this is the movie
for you did you just get this out of the
garage that's why I keep it that should
be gone by now that's hard too hard say
goodbye Scott a nanny Howard finally buy
their dream house in Napa from former
owner Charlie Peck unfortunately for
them Charlie has a hard time letting go
so he doesn't know he's quite a guy you
know his wife died in that house do you
think that's blood
dude days of dropping by are over this
psychological thriller is for you if you
like home invasion horror films dreamy
Dennis Quaid as a psychopath as you lock
in your doors at night or like Dennis's
character you've realized just how hard
it is to buy a home these days buying a
home man so not fun that is your weekend
ticket what will you see and check back
next week for Ryan Reynolds as a Pokemon
yes
[Music]